Muslims have come up more in this
election cycle than ever before Donald J
Trump is calling for a total and
complete shutdown of Muslims entering
the United States
at the same time hate crimes against the
community are at their highest levels
since 9/11 but here's something you're
not hearing the Muslim vote is actually
pretty powerful in fact it could swing
the election I'm in Florida one of the
key battleground states that's home to a
lot of Muslims and their votes make a
difference when Bernie Sanders won the
Michigan Democratic primary earlier this
year it was in large part thanks to
Muslim voters who embraced his
progressive ideals but while two-thirds
of the community today leans Democrat it
wasn't always like this in 2000 they
largely supported george w bush who had
actively courted them and in a national
race that boiled down to just 537
ballots here in florida you can bet
those votes made a difference at the
timeless ylim voters identified with GOP
family values and felt the party was
stronger on civil liberties that quickly
changed after 9/11 when Bush waged two
Foreign Wars and ramped up surveillance
of the community and since then
Republicans have done little to win over
Muslims and Donald Trump certainly
hasn't helped
the Muslim community definitely feels a
sense of urgency around Donald Trump's
presidential election bid they're
definitely not voting for him they're
not planning from voting for him and if
anything they feel a sense of or urgency
to organize to reach out to register the
community to vote
Leila Abdulaziz is a community organizer
who works to register Muslim voters in
Tampa they feel that their civil rights
are directly under attack so I think you
know Muslims really really understand
that a lot is that stake for them and
for the future of their their lives and
their children in this country how does
the community feel about Hillary Clinton
you know the community is very concerned
about her messaging that commits to
putting more military presence in the
Middle East and I think they're also
very concerned about the way that she
only talks or she first and foremost
talks about Muslim American voters as
potential threats before talking about
them as citizens but despite those
concerns most of the Muslims that I
spoke to here appear to be voting for
Hillary even though she is not my
favorite person on all issues
she is the one that's actually more
responsive to the people Ashley who are
you voting for this election Hillary
Clinton why does Hillary earn your vote
because she realizes that Muslims are
people and we're not terrorists I'm
looking forward to vote for Hillary
Clinton
so what issues are most important to
Muslim voters well a 2016 study by the
Institute of social policy and
understanding found that after jobs in
the economy its bigotry and civil rights
and that's consistent with what I heard
from voters here
I think equality in the u.s. right now
justice equality being inclusive what's
going to happen with jobs as far as like
minimum wage goes Islamophobia is number
one of course being Muslim that is
pretty much the top issue that we have
here this holds especially true in Tampa
which has seen its share of recent hate
crimes a fire burned down much of this
mosque back in August and what
authorities ruled to be an arson and it
wasn't an isolated incident arsonists
have destroyed several other mosques and
Islamic centers in the area and many
Muslims here have even reported being
physically or verbally assaulted there's
a lot at stake this election especially
for Muslim Americans we know their votes
will have an impact but will whoever
gets elected actually serve the
interests of the community
you